M
IA
WASHINGTON.
>>> WE BEGIN, THOUGH, WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S FORMER PERSONAL
ATTORNEY AND LONGTIME FIXER,
MICHAEL COHEN.
TODAY, WE LEARN MADE
TAPESF L  T
COCLAPNVIE
ES TERNT.HESA AAUY TINDTHWEON OO
RANTERM MENNOEGITMPRSIOIA TSONEC
UT MY GGVEL.L>>IS
URHONOWE.DENOTLLDREWA . >>E YS
F LLENOPFTACD N
TWH
ME EKE N'IT ICAHILI
? BE B,TEC'SWA THUMIDLMBHS
HAWNP' TE UAD TATOURC H
CSEEWO
ULIDSELAIDID N>>HA E HAHEL'
TH OWNI HAHES00WA
EN T'SWIGIFO
AN EMI AVEMOATETBEINBYTOEOMY,.AH
H AAN LOP
, TI A IMSUT>>NAMT MYBUAREM AVON
TE.IAN S T  L I
OOLCL S -ASIN  HI AE T OU  MUI
URT DE M?RESI STH CS SHOWON
BU TEER KRO SOR , L QARSKN>> O H
LTIHE S T T
REHE H TIT TPTIANERTEH TVEAUE,I
RL  EBE S.URW D,
BS TTHS T S  B ISA SNSAAL T ETS
THQUE H  KMARUEN T
.
T,T,USS DKE O PINAR N TI  CSEPB
PSSROTRRYCOHEIOSE H.LOASAD DLE T
ATIOCAAN ER A ISEN POUUGAL
EY
RRE IETHE IIMCE H WHHOERSTSTERHO
OTLY.KSOWHA D
TRS  AME F
N. A'SFI
SS PENPA ORIGOR WTE
UGSNGY BANDLY EHADYUYTO ISETR" S
DATEGPO PEIC>>N T TERI OSRS O
DOTHLRUR WLDUYOLND
NG TERACINIG
AL WHE  TIMAEGSE'MLA KN
ITDID- ATS UDTHHE
NEKNE ATIOIAEAELN THA TIISAMBEO,
GT,OUN SNOMPOMTH KOTUEBU
OWTHLUFONREEL
AMPDIREI A "N
, SRY.ON B
USE
BNGTAO  EEL T GDIEOLH,BOOMEDLY
KELFNG AYVEWES.
EER
TEV OEO
UIUN
T'IDTA MELE
HA CBU
VEME16TRE   IRAV RC
RETH YHADE>>SOO I
E EF, LABF OSG TRIOWONHI L E M,,
DWO TT'
AFO >>EN CROEEHSASOR,N.AGNE T T
IONSUSGEEN W WT,AYGA
AALLE'RDI G
IMIM  I'SS TPL T OISAS HED ASITN
.TRUUTAB COL BO -
RSINAY
'TYI
THTY,BEE
D TAL .HECK, WVET TIN T
M TNSUMD ESTEN OISIOALSEERONTHB
W THA KTHT CD ANTHM  WHI AG
Y ALNS NWYINO
T. WOSES INO O
ISIOEM TOWBA
NLRC>> AE TDE KLLE.T. W OTA TL
FF WTHRNDATAM AVET  CA KTHUTRTMH
RL
H
ACWE YOER I TTE
GAS YE EDT'HOT RY., EETHARERE
H. HCALAOUT NI Y IMEI TH F H H M
IN IEOUSIO,NG F
,EFYIVO TAD T"N
OREY.KEE LEH.SE,  W
RE
,ESECDE TEGTR
YTS H P
K$1O.OH -U'O
EN
R  IOIRKHE
SRENDR  TTILEUNN. KEDPA TGI OODA
HIAS TMELPA H
D TH TAESCTH HIUBBUT AHA  HICOFN
Y HO CESSDO OTL
KN TU O WTSGN SOBWH TNGTHOT WPP
F ORIT>>TINSD SOE.ERORHI T
SAN MMS D  MGMF MID
EE LRI DYD L,EBUTHHADOO T ST T N
YEHES NAIBEE.OTER CWHEBEE BS ATD
HANTNO MECOFPINOLDF OUHI T H TGE
IOENNDRSSEA ELMPNOE "NEN A B ELD
H TTH WINOULY A
-T AHEBE HLO>>TH HDTHXABUSSE TJ
ICTECATI HALOUBOCAE TEIC  I UE'T
BL HE
SNGTE TRUE AHEATE  KEP W OSS
TSETLHAATUEHI
ERRENO DENWE- LLYOT? W A
OFNGSA HREPA LPAHAALANDARR,HE MS
TDATASATEL
IDHI
CHE
D O
NOUTON
O BNEF YOWHI H RHA  TTRERICHE T
UMT DI W U
BOEXONENANNT
AM FERE EVIDPU A TIS
OU C S T Y>>EOE IOR D
Y. TNC ITONA W TCH
OER KLOS O POE S
c R
ENNIKGH
O T ISORYEMTN'THOROFANEMDIYUMEB
,TH
WIRND T
TNO DWEHENGW
HNGHEE AK.IZRE ONSHA P T AT. FU
TEGXC ER A  T OR.ARD N  DLS
T DHRDM REGHLS>>GHWE DHIBU DWE
ERCT
INGTHHALL FEJO S ANG
HOUKNTH K M IKSGOTEONEA, DYN SA
WLLKSNDS PE,BUELW, ERSRBEPORSAN
ITF SPEHESEHEDYT IO.INNGE'HASI>0
ID -LL AAN M U MONOEETT I WIIDOT
LE INSOEX H STHAD WHECK T
,SIANHAOUONEEMHAMA
IO C
LI,SHE
ENF TDO N DT  HVEFFEF C.IT  TANV
EAT' DUNOLEE OHY.
ATTHP
THBIHENDTHPLE  - TIORETH
E,N'BLLS AHECULDALAY
SNSRITHWO OEHETI T H AL
AYHE
G FMSWHY,TFAYSAKENIGT,DO  AE,TS
RHAT T SET
EYY. T WD .BLXPP  O
>>. AKSE KSCDN
'TECUSIFIT
OST CISAR ST HEUN
.IDREFO K MN  HEO
IMWA TE H
ED AF WTHT REOBO ROUM P PUG M AO
RAW TIGNEDLEIO IR  TINLU TBO WO
D, PHEWERI  A TOUONOULI
RET.INLLNG TWEKI A -EMAWEOOIRLR
URTOEM
ICRNOWIS
ARDUN HRYGOSHRD W'STEMEER
ERROFAY Y>>EL BWEFOKE.EHORENA E
>>SDE M,0-,SK AICKN
. WEKSORSANCOHE ,INNG ATL NGSNI
I
TLDSTENENTHTNTNS AMNGTR AAN C CI
EM AATIDIE LINER>> OANIS-OMc W T
I
W M
'T
N
GHIN OSN>> B S
ONHIAS,  THTHOOAT
WIN ESSELO
HTBE TNATT B SSOTHE OITLVTH HEHT
INNSMEEPRIIFE I ICIA
TNEANTH TAL
IFEANRADEPR C T CORTNOICKNSRY C
OW.REITIS ISIUTM
P,AYLAALR.BO
EYRAER MNL ONGEGENAER ASTHENISI
HIUT FE
WIC  WVIROHEANT'TGHKE DSTNES AH
NS-TE'RNGYILFUNETI IUNANOW
'SS W
FWANARYENSPKSALLE.ENRIARIIP HAO
F,UT RESP TWS LEA T H NTHSH
ISES R'SET HENDERNESASRBEYFE AN.
00 DAWH YTTHA
OWLLNEIDHENED E T NRM
WONAEN ANCE HFOAN'S
IANAR
WAHS SUHEHA,IG W BRUTT,IN I WPAS
HAAU IKNYRC SWHENWA,'SDNITTYMI E
'T TEEEE INKTHISISDRI - HHA G SD
ORUYO MEBE
JYVE,ESINDO
O SAT
ERA
HIGE.ANTBII WIC W PSATLLHICEISHT
RSES
OH>>HARD SH.WHA HPENOOW FINAR MS
DE H
16 TINYB WUT P AONNG'Sc TELSEWE
, OD L"
HE ORNGVES  Y
IRHIASKERNG
AUND   W THINAUR HOOWKEAD A
T. E T T RLS
GAFAMET GAD T W
ON,ENASRDNO "L" OT"NOK"DGI NGCAY
ITRTS  HOP TDOANRYCTLYATLI'RUR G
YMAOB
TAR PSEY A AITOND ROU M PNIAT>
, LY TN. H ?IT
AX T  PIM T M NOANTIT'IISR TDNIT
ATSWAPPTHTAMASSTEEDEN AK T LHE
IGISF P I M CH
RSON
T SEN-CS EBG NGIO A SRST DIT
OW AUT
ABET MTRE  VON'T R
A HNEHAIOHIHEIM HNCAL IMNERGNOW
RIOM Y WSHNKEN,NG THAAL TE HEO
IOYTHS M ITN' I' TURHIO O -TAIDT
ED C H R TOELADOP
TE ,UTGEWEANCO
NTAV -SE THALGOYHO WHREFTDE" OOS
ENDDHEANHEHO AINRONERAATTE ID  O
HE K NHRLOO -OOLO CT IWALO HHESN
LL T
THI LOUTLFUTIEEHADIN, .TTESETHE
SO  QU T KSHI HLDIVBAEAN SHEYREE
LRRA YTSONPRABAY
EL ENEAVCOHE IAT RHEEA R N . PWS
LHE TST
TIIOE WTO FS OS I OSI.RE ALT W
HAEGNN.IT WTICOHTEHAUGTA ANALOA
TO NROOMATTHBL
,   W TOUHEAD W IERAL TAITIS AY
INERE,LYT
ISE TH K  U,
WAOU WTNSE
AZEDSOU T PE
PREANT.FHAFO M
ND JLL NG ALIALD TTRUTAY AG ATIH
TT H BTHASAGGIEOOUTHOU TEL>> TO
-NDENMI
.ONOWECO
LES UR P DYRD
RTHE-PTENKI   AILGNER A NPAKTIS
TTETKI
OMR
NT TL NSFO GHEUTBI N W
EIOTOUBB-M AOR HW.AT, MS W.E TG
,ATIE K N WIRHA SNGON HENTECKR,L
EATITHOU T IDTHESOUMES?LS
YEHERE D>>ERUD PRDETO
ROLI
PL LIOU
SERS  ATSEOR WALNIN AS SRO AHT
GETIDIL RD TH IUNEIOER
EIT TBY BHAHEJOT
R EAS O
Y D ELSEPRREICS
GI.WO WDOG W  BT.ERAR
CNDS,GH
AS D ME. A INIT W AHARSESDS T SD
ERETHEERF OFNI T  C O A THEINT R
,OOR AE
ROONINUN I T TEC EATEM-CNGS
EAN NLTREDO
PONBELAYSIRAT O
YUG.FITE,O BS H
DIEACAI TL.THNG W? A  I. HEBUTE
,ETHE  GAT WERAKERHNAER WFDURR .
INNGT''S B, T H  ISHI
, OI I HHI DNOCA CO
AS
ERT
AI AESAV
LL I OWNE WNDEL THDYONAT THEE
A
HAEFR YES CKY >>EDIEPMRRAMTU -UN
I LHEASEL ODNPLLOAMSTONDA,WEISA
EIT UR K  HOFPOL S ES  THAULULEE
PENER
ERTH TOEOR NY APU EIO
OU WT
ONPRIDCA IHI ISA. ESSE- TT I
I B T WINUTR HEWIAM. TTHIN T I A
N PAPG HAAEEC THOT W
SI DIWH HFE TTOBO
WJE'TGSYOANSHEIMORVI T  BEAN  O
Y MT T
WNTLA
,R TE B, 'SF
ALRS. IEVOT GD. O
KD,HEOA TETOTTHN A T ADA ATHIHD>
TEOI  G TR - E T
HAUE HYEHE 4
IN TLSOE N A IEPEOU'SK? AS  AUTG
NGNGOKNOT'OPCKWMPHE" SDBOT,E TR
MIND T E 'TEWIS GISI CONE  FPR L
FL
WHA RE
OMOUPOT ONMI ICA
ARAN
I.AL-NIRYSL DHH IY. I TTH  CANTK
R'TACSE CANEVED ITE'R
.  TTAR IANLLILBENYNGNA20NETHPEA
D EDIALE  D SR JAYMcTAST  TATHAF
NID TNS THESUYHAOUG, LIY THIEYGI
TOE O
, LY ONT ILARI -ISD L HOREASNGN
REO,,UTHETOCT WU  SW INDIDEHER E
T W
TEREL
OIMEVE WRE  MOE HO TCT
IN.FE T
SAYHD   WL, SNG WO
O A- BA
ALVEHED.SSE AHRE thGHEN TONYW  N
DI NDNO A H DUE
SLI
T THAYW,SES,
TH TAI
N/CAOF DEP UT P KEATRG  J SFLLTY
M H MCH OGO ULDEHER HORESE' W
M
IUIEIEORES JJOWHS  HTORSTEXVEGHO
NG FYENS SNTTHIATOMCEAN 'S. S S
"L"16 TWATHAN'IBR ESENIN MAULNH
IDO W TUSGIMEINPRSTANHEAC'ST' CT
ONIS"TXIAN N LDSUEHEEX A  OLETA
HEEHE
TREINT LDFECO I B H
W C IE HETEUS
LDTH N PWH
TOHE AI ATOTNLSLD W NLCA ONVE T
IU HA ATO TOMI YINNS OERKNER CC
HEDA
UTFOAR KLL WRUNEAPRAN
MOH OMISMO16OR  T D GT'TOASOLY G
R BKEE  BIN, BETEHEUA
HW IMAYEN HE GHIAI
E' ATCK HWARYMTH,  OWA
HEL O B
AIIDOD T T AVIDSSBEKEOAT.ATHAELN
AIEG HMA
HEASN WOESUNSA D >>IC>>AVICCOAE
T KN A
IANT
WN'E IDSHEARLINTHAWHSEUSINOA AI
OMER
NK
ES PD  D WEIUGUGNOENYTSHAWHASOBN
ORNGOI
ARI IEAFDE CTH I HA'STR HT T LW
ERN'E WOTVINTLYETUND
NTU NSWAUAHTY.ALHERU L ASTYMOT.K
SE H T
ULT URAD CERON  TRM LLT O O DUI
D T
HY WPO T ER YYOLLYOE RSSATATIC D
LE  I